welcome to this video playing Paul du
jour pointe du jour 8 out of 11 is the
score I think we had this before right a
Queens gambit declined exchange always
like this opening from white sir gives
white a good structural game and no no
development problems or anything like
that okay with the h3 interesting ok so
is playing a totally different here form
c5 interesting night is on the 7-eleven
so it's not much pressure on the form of
course I can take but I really don't
want the IQ p.m. situation here not
because it's bad but i just want them
want to have a slightly different
slightly different setup i'm playing a
bit using this night on this seven
saying that as long as opponents on d
for the night is not in a particularly
great spot and again here the night is
somehow clogging up blacks play I want
to go with 95 soon interesting way to
play he wants to play night if form and
I see
so 95 it's really the normal way to play
on 92 maybe I can also go night a to
trying to ask him if this is really such
a great square or nighty too many ideas
interesting 92 to g3 maybe let's try
that it's a it's an original solution
and again asks black what is doing with
this night this is why I didn't want to
play 95 early am because I wanted to get
in there without him having the
opportunity to exchange it directly
nigeria maybe even g5 as possible an
interesting position here with b5
possibly coming try to get more pieces
to the King side here night h5 maybe but
he definitely has a has a decent game
that that's clear um look a successor
move intending knight c6 it's not clear
that it helps me that much
yeah but probably it's still an
activation of my rook it also prevents
Bishop t6 hmm does it prevent Bishop t6
it looks we add we should be six putting
it and in those in the focus of the rook
and the bishop oh wow I thought I can
just go knight c6 now why is this not is
not possible um okay yeah let's play
that first and then think about it think
about it again or is he really able to
player no he cannot play Queen d6 I have
night takes a six right if everything
else fails
night is ok he needs to give the Queen
yeah but this is not not entirely clear
night too ok let's capture and get in
Bishop to g5 activating activating the
bishop I don't play that because I want
to trade I want to get more activity on
the on the kingside g4 age 45 maybe yeah
to get direct play I think on the on the
kingside his King situs is really
weakened and then I can use my bishop
here for good effect if i take f6 now is
this an idea then take g7 but this is
also good right where is he going with
the night it's really no good square
take age 6 now if it takes you five i
have maybe f4 or queen h5 a queen h5
looks looks ok I'm attacking the night
night f7 that's age seven not sure that
he still has a move left
97 how do I actually win then I don't
see a win against that as well that's
not good at least no no direct win but I
don't want to let the clock tick down
much more this keeps is six under fire
and just wants to get this back which is
probably a good idea root g1s my idea oh
I didn't see that you can take with the
rook mmm okay check
time warning rook h1 check rook h1 is
coming I here I've actually double the
taking this route and the bishop
the land resign loses more material yeah
I think this was a very very unclear and
interesting position around here when we
look at this he definitely should be a
quite okay if he is not allowing 96 the
computer is really giving bishop t6
which looked a bit fishy to me somehow
because it looks it looks technically
dubious but maybe there really is
nothing i was thinking that maybe
something like this could be on oh it is
on so this means that he must take with
the rook ok this is this is coming quite
nice so he must take with the look and
my interesting move by the stock fish
queen a one taking the a file yeah maybe
why this somewhat better but it's
nothing nothing special yeah and this is
after knight c6 losing material you must
give up the Queen now he really has no
move if he plays something like that
he's running into this which loses Sam
in exchange at least gentium I try to
quickly get something on the Kings side
which was at least decent a belief yeah
the the engine is giving giving me a big
big edge all the way so i guess it was
it was ok oh yeah should take this is
stronger because of rooks ammonia ok i
didn't see that at all Brooksie seven or
luke c8 now this double threat is too
much ok so this was much clearer but it
was an ok game I think
thanks for watching